I therefore, a prisoner for the Lord, urge you to walk in a manner worthy of the calling to which you have been called,
with all humility and gentleness, with patience, bearing with one another in love,
eager to maintain the unity of the Spirit and the bond of peace.
There is one body and one Spirit, just as you were called to the one hope that belongs to your call,
one Lord, one faith, one baptism, one God and Father of all,
who is over all and through all and in all, but grace was given to each one of us according to the measure of Christ's gift.
Therefore it says, when he ascended on high, he led a host of captives and he gave gifts to men.
In saying he ascended, what does it mean but that he had also descended into the lower regions, the earth?
He who descended is the one who also ascended far above all the heavens, that he might fill all the things.
And he gave the apostles, the prophets, the evangelists, the shepherds and teachers,
to equip the saints for the work of the ministry, for building up the body of Christ,
until we all attain to the unity of the faith and of the knowledge of the Son of God,
to mature manhood to the measure of the structure of the fullness of Christ,
so that we may no longer be children tossed to and fro by the waves and carried about by every wind of doctrine,
by human cunning, by craftiness and deceitful schemes.
Rather speaking the truth in love, we are to grow up in every way into him who is the head, into Christ,
from him the whole body, joined and held together by every joint to which is equipped,
when each part is working properly, makes the body grow so that it fills itself up in love.
This is the word of the Lord.
It's so good to be back together and it's good to be able to return to the book of Ephesians.
So, yeah, if you've got a Bible, do keep it open there at Ephesians
or keep it in front of you there in your worship guide.
Julie and I have been away for the past couple of weeks,
so when I talk about us being away or good to be back,
we've been out of the country for a little bit.
It was great to be in England and while we were there, we celebrated Christmas with family,
but we also went down to London to see the Lion King, to see the musical.
And it was really amazing.
We enjoyed that.
But if you've ever seen the Lion King, be it the musical or the movie,
you'll know that everything kind of hangs on Simba, the Lion King, remembering who he is.
And when he finally embraces who he truly is, he returns to his kingdom
and it is all the better because of his return.
Well, here in the book of Ephesians, we saw in the first half
that it is all about who Jesus truly is.
But when we see who Jesus truly is, we can also find our own identity in him by being in him.
We find our identity in Christ.
But if you find your identity in Jesus, it will impact the way that you live.
So who you are will be seen in how you live.
So that's what the second half is about.
And you see that connected here in chapter 4 and verse 1.
The first half is really those first three chapters.
The last half is chapter 4 to 6.
But chapter 4 verse 1 begins.
I therefore, a prisoner for the Lord,
urge you to walk in a manner worthy of the calling to which you have been called.
So he's saying, I therefore, on the basis of everything we've already seen
about what God has done for us in Christ,
urge you to walk in a manner worthy of your calling.
So the calling he speaks of here is this calling of God for us to be in Christ.
So if you put your faith in Christ, you've been made new in him.
You've been united to him in his death and resurrection.
You're part of the new humanity that God is creating called the church.
This is the calling being spoken of here when God called us to himself in Christ.
And if you're part of this new humanity in Christ,
you need to hear this call to walk worthy of your calling.
So the walk being spoken of here is a is a continuous way of life.
So if you're Christian, God has given you a new life in Christ,
not so that you might merely exist in this new life,
but that you might live the life that God has given you, the life that you were made for.
He's laid out a path for you to walk now. Walk it.
And this morning we are particularly going to see though,
is that we do not walk this path alone.
The life that we were made for is designed to be lived together in community.
We live in a culture that despite being more connected than ever through things like smartphones
or social media is starved for authentic community.
But the thing is that together life that people are longing for is fulfilled in Jesus.
It's found in him and it is to be experienced in the life of the church,
this community that God is creating.
Sadly churches don't always live this out.
And even when churches are living this out, we can miss out on it personally.
But what Paul writes here under the inspiration of God's Holy Spirit can be a real help to us.
So for the next few moments I just want us to see three things that should characterize our life together as a church.
So what is this life together all about?
What should characterize it?
Well first of all, our life together should be characterized by unity.
I recently heard something and I can't remember where I heard it,
so it may very well have been from one of you.
So forgive me for not quoting you if you told it to me.
But it was about a guy who was stranded on a desert island
and he was out on this remote island, had been there for months and months and finally,
people found out he was there and they went to rescue him and they came there
and there he was with the three huts that he had built.
And they said, well what are these three huts that you've built here?
He said, well this one here is my house.
And he said, and this one here is my church.
And they said, okay well what's the other hut?
And he kind of looked over his shoulder, rolled his eyes and he said,
that's the church I used to go to.
So you can't have one church without having the other church that you don't speak to anymore.
It's funny because there's a grain of truth there.
Because instead of unity, all too often churches are marked by, or even scarred by, division.
There may be times when a church forsakes the gospel and it's necessary to move away there.
But all too often it might be because people can't get along with each other
even over the smallest of issues.
So walking this path together as the church requires unity.
We are to be as Paul says in verse three, eager to maintain the unity of the spirit in the bond of peace.
Now unity doesn't mean uniformity.
The unity being spoken of here is unity in diversity.
So in chapter three we saw that the church is made up of Jews and Gentiles alike.
We are part of one body.
So no matter what your ethnic background is, we are part of this one body together.
And here we see, Paul's going to add to this, that the church is also made up of all different types of members with different gifts.
So God is weaving together this beautiful tapestry of all different sorts of people from different ethnic backgrounds,
cultures, classes, ages, personalities, different gifts.
We are diverse but God is uniting us together in Christ.
And the question is, well how do we live out this unity in diversity in practice?
Well it's going to involve at least a couple of things.
It's going to involve what we might call our position and our disposition.
So it's knowing that we are united, that's our position,
and then making the effort to live like we are actually united together in Christ.
If it helps, maybe think of a three-legged race.
I don't know if you ever did that in field days growing up.
I remember when I was a little kid, you'd go and you'd line up
and normally in a race you'd just kind of take off running and it's all down to you and how fast you can run.
But in the three-legged race you're paired with somebody and they get like a velcro strap and it strap you both together.
And you can't just take off running, you've got to learn to walk together and then to run together to try to win the race together.
And so this is what we have here.
So we have been united together in Christ so we already are joins together.
Now we must learn to walk together in Him.
Alright so our position, we are one.
We've been united together in Jesus.
The German pastor Dietrich Bonhoeffer wrote a little book on Christian community called Life Together.
And I totally stole the name for the title for this sermon this morning.
But it's a great little book and I would encourage you to read it.
But he wrote something striking about Christian community in it.
He said this, he said, Christian community is not an ideal we have to realize,
but rather a reality created by God and Christ in which we may participate.
Right so it already exists we don't create it.
But we can participate in this Christian community.
So in a moment we're going to see yes unity is something we have to work on but it's first something that is given to us already.
We already have it. We're already united.
We're already one.
And so Paul drives this home here repeating the word one seven times.
Do you see it in the passage? He says one over and over again.
There is one body, one spirit, one hope, one Lord, one faith, one baptism, one God and Father of all.
And he's writing this in a way that's showing us where our communal life together,
our common life together as the church comes from.
And it comes from the triune nature of our God who is Father, Son and Holy Spirit.
So you see that our unity comes from the unity of God, this one God who exists in three persons.
So do you see the Holy Spirit present here and how he phrases this?
So he says there's one body and one spirit.
So you personally, you are not just a body. You're a unity of both body and spirit.
So in a similar way, the church, the body of Christ has one animating spirit, the Holy Spirit of God.
So the same spirit of God gives life to everyone who puts their faith in Christ.
So if you belong to Christ, the Holy Spirit of God dwells in you and the person next to you and the person over here.
The same spirit dwells in all of us.
We're in Christ part of his church.
That's the Holy Spirit. But you also see the sun here.
See this in verse five. There is one Lord.
Now this is Jesus. If you go back to chapter one of Ephesians, we already saw that Jesus is the one who is now seated at God's right hand in heavenly places far above all things.
He is the head of the church.
When it speaks here of the one faith, this is the body of doctrine that tells us about who he truly is.
This is who we are called to trust in.
We are united to him in one baptism as well. It mentions here.
So by the spirit of God, we are baptized into Christ.
So we're united to him by faith. We're united to him in his death and in his resurrection.
And that is the baptism that we share by the spirits.
We're baptized into Christ. We're united to him.
And this is then reflected, this inward reality, this inward spiritual reality is of course reflected in water baptism as well.
Showing that we are united to Christ in his death and in his resurrection.
So it's pointing us to the sun here.
We're pointing to the Father because there is, verse six, one God and Father of all who is over all and through all and in all.
So the ground of our unity with each other is the unity of the triune God.
God is one and yet he exists in this loving, eternal community of three persons, Father, Son and Spirit.
So John 17, Jesus prays for the unity of the church.
And here's how he prays for his father. Keep them in your name that they may be one even as we are one.
So in Christ we are one.
But unity is also something we have to work on.
We're told here to be eager or to be diligent to maintain our unity.
So you might think of it this way.
If you're born into a family, they're your family, whether you like it or not.
But it's a lot better to get on with your family and to work on living together as one loving family.
So it's true, like if you are in Christ, you are part of the family of God.
So we are united in that sense, but that doesn't mean that we don't fall out and kind of try to keep our distance from each other.
So there's another sense in which we've got to work on unity.
It has to be maintained.
It begins with our disposition towards one another.
We got our position. We are united. Our disposition, if I can get it out, is here too.
So Paul lists out a number of character qualities. I wonder if you saw them in verse two.
And these are character qualities that foster practical unity.
But interestingly, all of them are inward qualities.
They deal with the tone of the church.
You might say the vibe of the church, our relationships.
Like what do they give off here? It's what's going on inwardly.
So notice what we're invited to. Humility is where it starts.
So humility is a lowliness of mind.
It's instead of having a high view of ourselves, we humble ourselves before God and with others too.
When it comes to the church, we come with an attentiveness to others, putting them before ourselves.
He then talks about gentleness.
So instead of treating one another harshly, we deal with one another graciously and kindly.
And sometimes that may take restraint.
But unity can only be fostered through gentleness towards one another.
He also talks about patience, even bearing with one another.
These character traits aren't always easy because everyone we interact with doesn't necessarily come into it with humility and gentleness.
We will encounter the opposite. We'll encounter pride in one another.
We'll encounter harshness in one another sometimes.
And so we have to be patient with one another.
It's interesting that word bearing has mixed in with the idea of putting up with someone who's annoying.
Alright, so there's a real honesty that is here in what is said.
So just because someone is rude to us or whatever, that doesn't give us the right to strike back.
God is patiently at work in them and he can give us the patience to walk alongside them, even to bear with them.
But I don't want to give you the wrong impression with bearing because notice what it's followed up with, bearing with them in love.
So we don't bear with them begrudgingly, like really gritting our teeth and rolling our eyes and talking behind their back or something.
It's not like that. We bear with them because God has given us His love for them.
We know He loves them. We know that we're sinful people and He loves us anyway.
And so we love them because they are part of this one body with us.
So unity doesn't ultimately come from the right practices but from the right posture.
That's where it starts. A posture of love.
So God unites us and gives us this desire to be with one another.
And the unity we're called to is ultimately the unity of the Spirit.
It's what the Spirit of God is doing in our midst.
Okay, so our life together should be characterized by unity.
But also secondly, as we move on we see it should be characterized as well by ministry.
Our life together is a life of ministry.
I don't know if you saw any of the funeral of President Jimmy Carter this past week.
There's lots of interesting elements of it.
But one of them was just to see the Secret Service detail walking alongside the hearse.
And members of the Secret Service always have different code names for different presidents they work with.
And I wonder if you heard the code name for Jimmy Carter.
The code name was Deacon.
So they called him Deacon because of his commitment to his Christian faith.
That came through as they called him Deacon.
And the word Deacon is the word that is used for ministry in verse 12.
So notice this. It says that we are called to the work of the ministry.
We are equipped for the work of the ministry.
It's the same word that's used for Deacons.
People who are called to lead in particular areas of ministry or service.
But it's a service that we are all called to.
We're all called to minister to one another.
So notice how we're all called to it.
So in verse 7, although there's one church, there's a diversity of gifts that are given.
They're given to each one of us that we might serve.
So if Christ has graciously gifted all of us one implication is that we're all called to serve.
We're all called to serve one another with a gift that he has given us.
Verse 12, you see that the work of the ministry isn't sort of given to the quote unquote professionals.
It's given to every single believer.
Verse 16, we see that churches work best when every member is working properly.
So every member is called to be a minister, so to speak.
So the churches always operate in this way.
Well, unfortunately, the answer is sometimes no.
I've heard churches compared to soccer games where you have 22,000 spectators desperately in need of exercise,
watching 22 players desperately in need of rest.
I don't know if you've ever been a part of a church where that's the case.
We've got a handful of people doing a lot and a lot of people just kind of turning up.
The church is not a spectator sport.
Now, there could be all sorts of reasons why it ends up becoming that way in particular instances.
You might have leaders holding on to things rather than enlisting and equipping and involving others in ministries.
Other times an issue can be a lack of willingness or initiative from members who should be involved.
And there could be other factors at work too.
And oftentimes there's a number of things at work.
But that's not how it's supposed to be.
We're all called to the work of the ministry.
Can I just say that having lived overseas for 14 years, there's something that stands out about churches in the U.S. in particular.
And I'm happy for you to take me to task on this if you would like to.
But it's what I might call it the professionalization of ministry.
What do I mean by that?
What I mean is that American churches are far quicker to move past depending on every member ministry to hire staff to carry out the work of the ministry.
Now, what I don't mean by that, I don't mean like, oh, churches should never hire staff or we don't believe in that kind of thing.
There's sometimes when that is good and necessary and the right call to make 100%.
At the same time, we need to be aware of the danger of developing a consumer culture where we come to church to receive the work of the ministry.
We're kind of paying for the goods and we hope to get the goods.
You see what I'm saying?
We're all called to participate in the building of the body.
So the work is for all of us.
It isn't easy.
You might say, well, ministry, I'm not sure if I'm kitted out and ready for ministry.
Well, the good news is it's a work that we are also all equipped for.
So we're all called to it and equipped for ministry.
Where do we see that here?
So verse seven, Christ equips us by His grace.
You look in Mark chapter 10 and verse 45.
We see that the Son of man came not to be served, but to serve and to give His life as a ransom for many.
And it is this Christ who provides all that we need to serve others the way that He did.
And in verse seven, we see that Christ gives us the exact grace that we need to use the specific gifts and opportunities that He has given us to fulfill our ministry.
Then He goes on in verses eight to ten to make the case for how Christ does this.
He says He points to the humility and exaltation of Jesus.
So in order to accomplish His redemptive plan, Christ descended into this world and even into death.
But then He rises again victorious and ascends to His heavenly throne, having triumphed over His enemies.
And when He ascended, what do we read here?
It says He gave gifts to men.
He ascended that He might fill all things.
So when He ascended to His heavenly throne, from which He reigns over all things, He gave gifts to His church so that we might carry out His work in the world.
So today, one of the ways that Christ is accomplishing His good purposes in the world is by empowering His people by His grace to serve others.
So the one who reigns over everything right now, how can we see His reign?
How can we know that Christ is reigning in heaven because He has provided what we need to serve one another.
And as we serve one another by His grace and for His glory, His reign is made visible in the life of the church.
So He's given us what we need.
And He's the one who's able to do that.
But another way He does this, interestingly, in verse 12, we see that He has also given the church leaders.
So leaders are given to the church to equip the whole body for the work of the ministry.
And once again, it's not that they are called to do the work of the ministry and we are called to receive the work of the ministry.
There's not a kind of sharp division there.
We're all involved in the work of the ministry, but there's a particular responsibility of leaders to equip the whole body for the work of the ministry.
Equip was a medical term that was actually used to set a bone.
I don't know if you've ever had to have a bone set in place, but that was where it was used at the time.
So you might say that leaders are guiding members of the body to take their place in the work of the ministry and helping them to do that.
That's the responsibility of leaders.
It was also a word that was used in a different context to talk about furnishing a house.
Okay, so you might say this, that the ministry of leaders is providing what we need to develop church members that we might build one another up in Christ.
It's providing what we need so that we're able to minister to others as we're called to.
So what did leaders equip the church with so that the church might minister one to another?
Well, there's a hint of what these leaders give in the types of leaders that are listed here.
You notice there are five leaders.
So you've got apostles.
So let's do a quick run through.
Apostles are these foundational leaders in the life of the church who are appointed and sent out by Christ as his authoritative spokesman.
So that's the apostles.
And you've got the prophets.
These were also foundational leaders that brought God's words to the church.
And you've got evangelists.
These are gospel preachers.
They're proclaiming Jesus to people who have never heard about him before that they're devoting themselves to that.
And you've got shepherds.
So shepherds are pastors or leaders of the church who care for Christ's flock in local churches primarily through their teaching.
And then you've got listed teachers.
It's interesting there's a bit of a discussion as to whether or not shepherds and teachers or pastors and teachers are just referring to the same person or whether or not it's two separate things.
Because the responsibility of a pastor is to teach the church.
But also you can have other people who are teachers teaching the church who aren't necessarily pastors.
So I think there is some space for separating those out as well.
But what all of these five types of leaders have in common?
What do you see there?
All of their ministries are word based.
So how do they equip the church by bringing the word of God to the church?
So every member needs to hear the word of God.
And it's in the word of God that we are equipped with all that we need for the service that he has called us to.
So 2 Timothy 3 in verse 17 says that it is scripture that furnishes us with everything that we need for every good work.
It's like our physical bodies.
Food matters to your entire body.
No matter what part of the body you're thinking about.
Like food plays a part in that ultimately.
So just like physical food matters to every part of our physical body.
So the spiritual nourishment of the word is necessary for every member of Christ's body, the church.
So we all need to be equipped and shaped by the word of God.
And every ministry that we are involved in must be directed and governed by the word of God.
God does his work through his word.
So Christ gives every one of us the gifts we need and equips us by his word that we might serve one another in the church.
So the final point I want to consider is this.
It's really why we serve.
So our life together is characterized by unity, by ministry, and that is then for the purpose of maturity.
So we've been brought together that we might grow together in maturity.
I don't know if you've done this at home, but I know some parents or grandparents will have like a doorpost in their house.
When their child is growing up, they'll kind of like mark how high the child is, how tall they are.
Keep marking that you can look back and they were this height, this height, this height, this height.
So here in verse 13 we're given a measure of our maturity as the church.
So how do you measure the maturity of a church, the growth of a church?
It says this.
So we carry on in the work of the ministry, building up the body of Christ until we all attain to the unity of the faith
and of the knowledge of the Son of God to mature manhood.
Here's the measure.
To the measure of the stature of the fullness of Christ.
So what's the measure of a church?
Is it the number of attendees?
Is it the number of baptisms?
Is it the percentage of members serving as volunteers?
Is it financial stability?
What is it?
Those are all good things, but they are not the measure of the success of a church.
There was one measure that comes to the success of the church.
There's one measure that God is using.
What is it?
It's the stature of the fullness of Christ.
So we don't need to go to a whiteboard here in January to figure out what is our goal together as Trinity Fellowship for 2025.
What's it going to be this year?
Because we have already been given the goal.
Christ is the goal.
He is the measure.
So we've been brought together that we might know more and more of Him and that we might grow together in His likeness.
And as we grow in His likeness, we bear witness to the world around us.
This is who Jesus is.
So Christ's likeness is the measure of a church.
The thing is you can be sort of successful or impressive looking in other areas,
but if we fail in this area of Christ's likeness, then we've failed.
And there is a real danger that we face.
And Paul draws our attention after mentioning that Christ's likeness is the aim here, knowing Christ, that there's a danger we face.
So verse 14.
What is it? If we don't grow up in Christ, we will be like children tossed to and fro by the wind and the waves
and carried about by every wind of doctrine, by human cunning, by craftiness in deceitful schemes.
In other words, if we don't grow up in Christ, we are susceptible to be drawn away from what Paul refers to as the truth that is in Jesus.
So there's new ways of thinking and living that are always put before us, and they can distract us and even draw us away from the word of life.
They can draw us away even from Christ.
So if we're not mature in Christ, we're susceptible to the deception that is in the world.
We'll be tossed to and fro, gullible to lies.
So we face a danger if we don't know the truth that's in Christ, if we're not growing up in Him to look elsewhere.
But also we see it not just negatively but positively.
He shows us how we grow in Christ's likeness.
Now, the Lord is the one who builds His church.
Matthew 16, 18. Jesus said, I will build my church. It belongs to Him. He's the one who builds us.
But here we see that He also uses us in the building of His church.
In verse 16, we see that the body builds itself up in love.
So how does that happen? How does God use us to build His church?
The answer put simply is, when the truth is spoken in love, by speaking the truth in love.
So we grow in Christ's likeness when the truth of God's Word is proclaimed in the context of loving relationships in the church.
So when we're speaking the truth to one another, doing so from a place of genuine love for one another.
Both of those things need to be present simultaneously.
So there's two ditches to avoid here.
We need to avoid the mistake of avoiding or soft peddling the hard truths of God's Word and saying,
well, we really want to be a loving church so we don't want to get into those doctrinal issues that might divide us.
But there's another ditch to avoid as well.
And that is like holding fast to the right doctrine and being proud of how right we are in what we believe
and not having a loving environment for people to come to where we genuinely love them and walk alongside them as we grow together in Christ.
So a church that is growing in Christ's likeness is a church where both truth and love are present.
It's in the truth of God's Word that we come to see more of Jesus.
And as we grow up in him, the love of Jesus who laid down his life for us will be seen as we lay down our own lives for others around us.
So whatever else happens in the life of this church this year, whatever results we see or do not see, let's determine by God's grace to pursue Christ above all else
and pray that we might grow in his likeness.
So just in conclusion, this together life that we were made for is found in Jesus.
So how should we respond?
So what does that mean for me like over the next few weeks?
What does that mean for you over the next few weeks?
Three quick things.
One is come to Christ.
So if you're longing for community, that longing is ultimately fulfilled in coming to Jesus and coming to know God through him.
You will be disappointed by the church.
You will even be disappointed by this church.
But Christ is not disappointed.
And we can know his love when we come to him by faith.
And then when we come to him by faith, we're then invited to participate in this growing community project called the church.
So first of all, come to Christ.
And then secondly, come to church to just put it simply come to church.
Church is of course who we are more than what we go to.
But if we're going to receive what God has for us and to give to others what he's given us to give to them, we've got to be present with one another.
I heard an interview with Tom Hanks, that great theologian.
And he said, you know, sometimes I'm asked about different different characters I've done.
He's like, so Forrest Gump, people ask me like, how did you create this particular like magical scene with Forrest Gump?
Like, how did you do that? What is the secret?
He said, do you want to know the secret?
I'll tell you this trick.
I go there.
He said, the secret is go there.
He's like, some days when I go to work, I don't feel like going to work.
I feel really sad and I've got to go act out this really happy scene.
But I turn up and sometimes things happen that people say are magical.
He's like, sometimes I feel great and I've got to go act out this sad scene, but it's in going there that these things happen.
So it's not terrible advice for church life.
I don't know about you, but I don't always feel like turning up.
I don't.
But God is creating something beautiful in the life of His church and you won't experience it if you're not present with other believers in the life of the church.
And I don't just be coming to Sunday services to that.
That's part of it.
That gathering with others maybe in a home group or or informally throughout the week just going and spending time with one another.
But be present to one another that we might hear the truth and receive the love and grow together in Jesus' likeness.
Let's make it a priority.
And thirdly, so come to Christ, come to church and get involved.
If the body of Christ grows when every member is involved in ministry, then that means you're needed.
Like we really need you here.
You matter.
Every single one of you matters.
You are part of what God is doing here to grow us in the likeness of Jesus and bring him glory in the world.
So serve one another in the grace that he supplies.
Let's pray.
Lord, it is such a privilege to be part of your family.
It's a Lord I pray that you would help us by your grace to live out this calling.
Lord, we thank you for bringing us to yourself.
And Lord, I pray that you would give us a growing desire to be with you, but also a growing desire to be with one another.
Lord, as we are with one another, Lord, I pray that we would increase in our love for one another.
And Lord, we would have an eye to how we might serve one another.
Lord, whatever you have in store for us over the coming months, over this coming year, Lord, I pray that we will be more like Jesus than we were when we began.
So we pray that you would accomplish your work for your glory in Jesus' name. Amen.